bonjour bonjour Alain Minc merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin vous êtes essayiste
et auteur de ce livre dictionnaire
amoureux du pouvoir séchz plomb on va
longuement parler à la main qu'on a
évidment envie d'avoir votre regard sur
le climat social et et politique actuel
dans le pays et d'abord c'est plus de
1700 actes antisémites qui ont été
recensés depuis le 7 octobre et puis on
a vu cette mobilisation dimanche dernier
cette marche civique contre
l'antisémitisme qui a réuni près de
200000 personnes à travers tout le pays
est-ce que pour vous un sursut national
a eu
lieu d'abord je voudrais dire que je
préfère de ce point de vue être français
qu'anglais il faut proportionner les
choses quand il y a eu une manifestation
propalestinienne à Paris il y avait
20000 person personn dont 15000 bobo LFI
à Londres il y avait 300000 manifestants
proalestiniens pour disait-il une
Palestine de la mer au fleuve
c'est-à-dire qui était un slogan qui
supposait la disparition
d'Israël il y a pas de manifestation en
Angleterre comme il y en a eu en France
il y a la plus grande communauté
musulmane d'Europe 6 million et demi et
juive je pense que c'est cette
résurgence antisémite est insupportable
et mais je pense que la France est un
pays qui résiste mieux par son modèle ou
ce qui le reste du modèle universaliste
par rapport aux pays qui sont en modèle
communautaire et l'absolu démonstration
sont les États-Unis quand vous pensez
qu'il y a une espèce de tremblement de
terre dans les universités américaines
d'une intensité rare où au nom de la
solidarité toutes les formes de victimes
on passe du vquisme au réflex
propalestinien je dirais que la France
va moins mal que les autres quand elle a
manif elle avait de la gueule elle était
fait de la gueule et il faut aussi la
regarder avec distance il y avait pas de
jeune que de jeune et la diversité comme
on dit entre guillemets n'était guère
représentée il y avait ça veut dire quoi
pour vous ben ça veut dire qu'il y avait
pas beaucoup de beurre cela dit il en
avait pas non plus à la MAN char pas
jeun c'est-à-dire je pense que la
sensibilité au sujet est une sensibilité
de la classe moyenne
supérieure centriste
macroniste éduqué et que ça c'est une
vraie interrogation c'est-à-dire c'est à
l'école que doivent se que les anticorps
doivent se former donc pour vous c'est
quoi c'est un échec de l'éducation c'est
un échec du travail de mémoire non c'est
un je je déteste l'expression échec de
l'éducation car quand il y a échec dit
de l'éducation c'est un échec de la
société dans son
ensemble vous évoquez vous parlez du
pouvoir juif le myth destructeur dans
votre livre vous nous avez parler de
résurgence de l'antisémitisme Bruno
rotaillot lui il refuse d'employer ce
mot résurgence il dit on n'est pas dans
une résurgence on est dans une nouvelle
forme d'antisémitisme on est passé d'un
antisémitisme dont le Terrero était le
fascisme un antisémitisme don le terro
est aujourd'hui l'islamisme politique
est-ce que vous partagez cette analyse
d'abord il faut toujours dire de quel
lieu on parle moi je le dis publiquement
je me définis comme européen virgule
français virgule et accessoirement juif
et le choix des mots et l'ordre des mots
est la seule manière de comprendre la
teneur ou Dison l'ADN de mon propos je
crois que reetaillot a raison sauf que
vous avez employé le mot antisémitisme
fasciste c'est pas vrai l'antisémitisme
de de la fin du 19e siècle et
l'antisémitisme de l'entre de guerre
était marginalement fasciste c'était un
antisémitisme de la France réactionnaire
il a complètement disparu et reetaillot
a raison et il est bien clair que la
matrice aujourd'hui de l'antisémitisme
mais on l'a vu arriver depuis longtemps
on savait très bien que à un moment
donné l'an l'anti sionisme deviendrait
le masque de l'antisémitisme bon on y
est et c'est vrai que cet antiématisme
est pour l'essentiel islamo gauchiste ou
gauchiste c'est-à-dire que très étonnant
de regarder le le tweet de Jean-Luc
Mélanchon qui est un homme qui connaît
le sens des mots et qui connaît la
lecture psychanalytique des mots quand
il dit à propos de la prison de
l'Assemblée nationale elle campait
dit pas elle était allée dit elle
campait à téavive pour soutenir les
massacres et cetera il sait ce qu'il
fait donc d'un côté le vrai
antisémitisme est Islam gauchiste et de
l'autre il y a une tonalité très
spécifique qui renoue avec la vieille
tradition qui fait qu'il y avait eu
aussi un antisémitisme d'extrême gauche
même joresel a été à un moment avant de
basculer dans le drefusisme julged était
d'un antisémitisme débridé Carl Marx qui
était juif l'était pourquoi parce que
c'était en fait et c'est un un point que
je soulève dans ce petit bouquin c'est
que au fond le juif était assimilé à
l'argent et au
pouvoir au nom
d'ailleurs de quelque chose qui sans
qu'il y ait le moindre la moindre HCE
d'antisémitisme se retrouvait dans le
mot du général de Gaulle un peuple
d'élite sur de lui est dominateur qui
était à mon sens contredit par le
merveilleux des satimes où on voyait ind
déporté la main sur le pied sur la
barrière électrique disant sur de lui et
dominateur mais et de GA était tout sauf
antisémite donc c'est ça qui fabrique la
la mythologie qui tourne autour de la du
mythe antisémite mais quand quand vous
dites Jean-Luc Mélenchon il sait ce
qu'il fait en employant ces mots est-ce
que ça veut dire que vous desselez chez
lui une for
d'antisémitisme non je pense qu'il joue
avec l'antisémitisme le enfin Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a commencé socialiste de
gauche franc-maçon jorécien et cetera
peut pas être au fond de lui-même
antisémite mais il joue et il joue
pourquoi jeanl méanchon voit bien ce
qu'il veut faire il a fait un score
élevé dans les banlieux avec une
abstention forte tu veux faire un score
élevé avec une abstention moins forte
veut dire c'est une option claire
inacceptable mais de cynisme politique
donc il ils pavent le chemin de
l'antisémitisme pour décalcul élector
non il joue avec ce ces relant
antisémites pour marquer sa domination
politique des banlieux Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'était pas là dimanche
dernier Marine Le Pen en revanche était
présente est-ce que ça marque une étape
de plus dans la dédiabolisation moi je
suis totalement sur la position qui
avait été celle de Serge cllarsfeld je
me réjouis que le rassemblement national
fut là les arrièrespensées elles sont
évitantes le côté habileté politique il
est évident mais euh dites-vous bien que
si en 1938 euh les Croix de Feu et
l'Action française euh avait manifesté
contre
l'antisémitisme 40 ne se serait pas
passé exactement comme ça s'est passé
avec promulgation du statut des juifs et
la marche à la déportation donc que les
héritiers de l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui soit sur ce terrain-là quels
que soi les motivation on voit bien
qu'il y a derrière une manière en étant
aussi proche des Juifs de marquer la
distance avec le monde musulman c'est
quelque chose qui dont il faut
évidemment se réjouir est-ce que ça veut
dire que la page de l'antisémitisme elle
a tourné elle la page de l'antisémitisme
du Front national elle personnellement
j'en suis convaincu je pense qu'il y a
évidemment dans son parti des gens qui
portent encore des stigmates du passé
mais les gestes engagent ce qu'elle a
fait a une
signification elle a elle a pas un
chapitre particulier Marine Le Pen elle
un chapitre Le Pen avec son père pour
vous c'est la même chose ou pas non
c'est pas la même chose je pense qu'elle
je pense que elle elle souhaiterait
certainement que l'affiliation soit
moins nette parce que c'est quand même
encore un fil à la patte pour elle non
c'est pas la même chose moi je pense
qu'il faut combattre Marine Le Pen sur
non plus le thème moral mais sur des
thèmes politiques et pour moi il y en a
trois ou quatre premier thème politique
je pense qu'elle est toujours
anti-américaine et donc très mal à
l'aise dans le PACT Atlantique je pense
qu'elle subit l'Europe mais qu'elle est
toujours au fond d'elle-même hostile à
l'Europe je pense que elle a une vision
de la société du fonctionnement
politique de la société qui est
référendaire et populiste et n'accepte
pas le jeu des pouvoirs et
contre-pouvoirs et d'autorité tel le
Conseil constitutionnel et enfin elle a
une une politique économique telle
qu'elle l'annonce délirante comme était
celle de la gauche en 1981 à ce su près
qu'en 1981 la France n'était pas
endettée et pouvait se permettre un
moment de folie et qu'aujourd'hui en
réalité avec son programme économique
nous avons le le le taux d'intérêt qui
éclaterait et nous aurions un licole
autour du coup donc c'est sur ces thèmes
là qu'il faut la combattre mais est-ce
que pour vous il y a marine Le Pen qui
dit des choses pour arriver au pouvoir
et il y a marine Le Pen qui si elle
arrive au pouvoir sera une autre et fera
autre chose je pense qu'elle n'a aucune
idée de la manière dont on gère un pays
donc elle n pas même d'exercer le
pouvoir pour vous non mais je pense
qu'elle a un vrai problème mais que un
je souhaite ardemment qu'elle ne
l'exerce pas et je pense que son parti
d'une certaine manière même s'il se
forme à l'Assemblée un peu est un parti
qui qui est très éloigné de ce qu'exige
une pratique du pouvoir c'est un métier
l'expérience ça existe c'est pas dans
cette maison qui regorge parfois à
l'excès d'expérience et qui a une
arrogance de l'expérience qu'il faut le
dire mais on l'a bien vu et c'est
d'ailleurs tout le problème au
fond de du macronisme le problème du
macronisme c'est que c'est un mouvement
à travers son chef qui manque
d'expérience
politiqueérience la PO c'est un métier
on va on va en parler d'abord un mot
puisqu'on va arriver à Emmanuel Macron
est-ce que son absence dimanche pour
vous c'était une
erreur un ami a fait une distinction
intelligente à laquelle j'avais pas
pensé je pense que le Président de la
République n'a pas à aller à une
manifestation organisée par des partis
politiques dans la mesure où elle était
organisée par les présidents des deux
assemblées c'est-à-dire une émanation
plus au niveau de l'État je crois qu'il
mieux value qu'il y aille une fois qu'on
a dit ça c'est malencontreux c'est pas
la fin du monde il y a pas plus rétif à
l'antisémitisme qu'Emmanuel Macron qui
pense comme pensaient les manifestants
alors Emmanuel Macron on va en parler
Macron du pouvoir de séduction à la
séduction du pouvoir c'est comme ça que
vous avez appelé votre chapitre la
politique c'est de la séduction le
pouvoir c'est autre chose non mais le
problème enfin j'en parle avec
l'affection que j'ai vis-à-vis de cet
homme que je connais depuis tellement
longtemps
que j'ai vu débuter je pense que le
problème de Macron qui avait théorisé
sur un grand bouquin intellectuel qui
s'appelait de kantorovic s'appelait les
deux corps du roi n'a pas compris qu'il
y a deux corps du président il y a le
corps gestion de l'État et il y a le
corps politique et que j'ai dit un jour
publiquement il y a deux mots en anglais
pour politique policie et Politi et j'ai
dit Macron police 17/ 20 là je trouve
c'est plutôt 14 he mais bon peu importe
et et politic 3/ 20 et je crois que si
il marche à cloch-pied c'est à cause de
ça c'est-à-dire qu'il ne sait pas je lui
ai dit un jour je crois que je l'ai dit
dans un entretien ou dans le bouquin la
politique c'est l'art du temps perdu je
je suis très sérieux l'art du temps
perdu c'est-à-dire sentir comprendre
nouer des alliances perdre à certains
égards son temps mais s'imprégner d'une
réal
et je pense que ça quand il n'a pas pu
le faire avant d'arriver au pouvoir
évidemment une fois que vous êtes devenu
roi de France vous êtes dans une
relation tellement biaisée avec le pays
que vous n'arrivez pas non plus à le
faire donc vous devez vous entourer de
gens qui ont cette pratique là et le
problème de Macron c'est qu'il ne veut
pas s'entourer de gens dont l'expérience
compenserait en réalité sa lacune sur ce
terrain comme il est mal entouré pens
peut-être à Alex
mais non mais moi enfin il est évident
qu'Alexis coller connaît encore moins la
politique qu'Emmanuel Macron donc c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est qu'il n' au
fond il avait dans son entourage deux
politiques
expérimentés Gérard colonb ça a pas duré
longtemps et jean- yy ledriant qui est
resta prisonnier de son couloir qui
était les affaires étrangères or c'était
avec ces gens-là qu'il fallait sentir le
pays c'est pas avec les ouv les jouvenau
de l'énarc de l'énar que je connais
mieux que quiconque est-ce que vous qui
connaissez bien Emmanuel Macron il a il
y a aussi chez lui une forme de
narcissisme qui pourrait expliquer ça
oui oui bien sûr bien sûr mais bon c'est
aussi un narcissisme qui a des excuses
que veut dire une telle TR trajectoire
météorique vous donne le sentiment à un
moment donné viscéral que rien ne vous
résistera et que la Providence vous a
chis enfin je le dis sous forme d'image
il ne cro il croit pas il ne croit pas
que la Providence l'a choisi mais c'est
vrai nos institutions sont des
institutions dire les ce sont des
institutions sous la forme qui est la
35e République héritière du grand sillon
monarchique français bon à partir de ce
moment-là quand vous êtes vous êtes le
monarque vous avez nécessairement une
perception fausse des choses donc il
faut vivre et s'entourer de gens qui ont
les pieds dans le réel est-ce qu'il
comprend les français Emmanuel
Macron je pense qu'il comprend les
Français et qu'il les connais pas et il
ne peut pas les connaître il les a pas
connu comme homme politique avant et
c'est pas dans les visites où le roi
touche les écrou et c'est pas sa faute
Hollande Sarko Chirac mitéran et tous
ceux qui président faisaient la même
chose je veux dire quand il va voir les
inondations c'est le roi et les
écrouelles bon c'est comm ont été élus
locaux avant est-ce que c'est ça qui lui
manque à Emmanuel Macron le fait de ne
jamais avoir été élu local oui j'en suis
absolument je suis absolument
convaincu je pense que c'est pour ça que
je dis politics
3 mais policie il y a eu de grands
moments en terme de policie alors qu
qu'est-ce qu'est l'apport de Macron qu'
on prend de la distance Macron un à une
politique européenne et grâce à lui
l'Europe est sortie renforcée deuxième
Macron a rendu la France entre
guillemets pour parler anglais business
friendly c'est-à-dire accueillante pour
le les capitaux du monde entier et une
terre d'attraction et troisièmement
Macron a fait que l'idée même
d'augmenter les impôts devient un propos
obsène bon c'est pas rien en France bon
c'est la seule chose c'est qu'il peut
pas aller devant le pays en disant j'ai
rendu l'idée d'augmenter les impôts
obsèes c'est évidemment contre-productif
donc l'essentiel de ce qu'il a fait est
quelque chose qu'il est très difficile
de transformer en argument électoral
mais c'est plus son
problèmeçou juste aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron il reçoit l'ensemble des chefs de
parti il a instaurer ça ce qu'on a
appelé les rencontres de cintis
dialoguer avec l'ensemble des chefs de
parti est-ce que c'est une bonne méthode
selon vous non mais c'était une jolie
fumerole mais le propre des jolies
fumeroles c'est qu'il faut pas la
rééditer c'était très malin une fois bon
pour le reste moi je suis pas en
désaccord avec un propos qu'a tenu je
crois cioti c'est qu'à la fin des fins
les conventions citoyennes les
rencontres des
SaintDenis le grand débat tout ça est
une forme
d'affaiblissement de la démocratie
représentative or on est à une époque où
les démocraties libérales qui prolifère
dans le monde encore qu'elles ont subi
une défaite éclatante et bienvenue en
Pologne on est à une époque où les
démocraties la tendance va quand même
vers les démocraties libérales donc il
est
d'urgence nécessaire de renforcer la
démocratie représentative donc on peut
s'en évader un petit peu mais pas trop
et lui il s'en évade trop il essaye et
puis à la fin des fins la réalité est
plus forte l'idée de de faire de voir
des gens qui sont incapables de
s'asseoir à la même table et qui s'inve
les voir se réunir tous les de mois dans
un climat apaisé c'est pas possible bon
c'est pour ça que il aurait dû se
contenter de la première fumerole qui
était brillante est-ce que c'est aussi
passib ce que vous dites c'est ça marche
aussi pour le mandat est-ce que les
présidents sont condamnés à rater leur
second mandat il devrait se contenter
moi je pense profondément
que la fonction il y a deux manières
d'exercer la fonction ou vous l'exercez
comme un roi comme François mitteran an
et c'est la bonne manière de l'exercer
et là vous pouvez faire de mandats ou
vous l'exercez comme un super Premier
ministre cas de Sarco cas de Hollande
cas de Macron et là au bout d'un mandat
en réalité votre capital politique et
votre capital de réflexion et votre
fraîcheur sont lourdement atteints et je
pense que de ce point de vue soit la
pratique présidentielle change et de les
deux mandats sont possible soit elle ne
change pas et le président ne peut
terminer user enfin il y a ce que Macron
a qualifié à juste titre même s'il
aurait pas dû le dire publiquement de
funeste conneries qui est la non
réélection pourquoi aux États-Unis ça
marche parce que il y a tellement de
pouvoir de contrepouvoir et on sait
comment ça se passe pour comme il disent
un L Duck presésident en France avec la
vision je l'ai dit monarchique un peu
sain du pouvoir dire qu'on est un roi en
CDD est quelque chose qui est
contradictoire avec la fonction or
Macron est un président en CDD et c'est
pas Macron c'est la réforme
institutionnelle de 2008 et à l'époque
j'étais pour cette réforme
institutionnelle et je pense que j'étais
je mais souvent en matière
institutionnelle on raisonne faux on a
été beaucoup dont moi à vooté le quinena
c'était une erreur on pouvait penser que
la limitation à deux mandats ça donnait
de l'air démocratique c'était une erreur
ce qui montre bien que quand on touche à
la Constitution il faut avoir la main
qui tremble vous parlez aussi des
prédécesseurs desmanuel Macron Nicolas
Sarkozi François Hollande on d'autres de
mais notamment on les a beaucoup opposé
ils se sont aussix beaucoup opposés
est-ce que malgré tout ils ont des
points communs lesquels Nicolas Sarkozi
et François Hollande pas
énormément pas énormément mais je le dis
parce que Nicolas Sar que j'aime
personnellement beaucoup à un moment et
c'est ce que je voudrais qu'on qu'on
garde de sa présidence apporter pendant
15 jours le monde sur ses épaules au
moment de la crise de 2008 avec un
président des États-Unis à moitié
dépressif et aux abonnés absents une
chancelière qui courait derrière lui et
qui était toujours en retard sur ce
qu'il fallait faire et que à un moment
donné il a sauvé l'économie de marché
c'est pas rien c'est pas rien il faut en
souvenir et quant à François Hollande
j'ai toujours pensé je l'ai dit écrit
dans ce bouquin il a très bien fait ce
qu'il n'avait pas appris au Parti
socialiste et il a mal fait tout ce
qu'il avait appris au Parti socialiste
en politique étrangère quandtin qu'un
premier secrétaire du PS ignore par
définition il a fait le boulot et dans
ce qu'il a fait il y a les accords de
Minsk il y a la réaction dans le Sahel
et il y a surtout le fait qu'il a tordu
le bras de la chcelière pour empêcher
que la Grèce sorte de l'euro or si la
Grèce était sortie de l'euro l'euro
risquait de mourir parce que le le fil
se serait débobiné en réalité l'euro a
eu deux sauveurs l'un que le monde
entier connaît qui est quelqu'un que
j'aime beaucoup à titre personnel qui
est Mario dragi whatever it takes et un
dont on parle pas mais qui a empêché le
club de se défaire qui est François
Hollande vous consacrez évidemment ce ce
livre au pouvoir quel est l'homme ou la
la femme de pouvoir qui vous a le plus
déçu dans l'histoire ou
aujdi les deux vous
choisissez Non ce qui ce vous voulez la
question elle va très elle c'est relisez
lestranches des faitte de Marc bloc au
fond c'est c'est comment une élite
arrive à perdre l'honneur du pouvoir
c'est une leçon qu'il faut méditer il
faut que le faire lire comme dans la
Russie soviétique on faisait lire des
samisd c'est-à-dire des livres
clandestins il faut le lire et le relire
voilà c'est ça qui était qui est
décevant et puis il faut savoir aussi
que l'histoire se joue un fil euh si
George VI finit par convaincre Lord
Halifax de devenir Premier ministre en
Angleterre en mai 40 les les Anglais
font une paix séparée avec les Allemands
et l'histoire du monde était autre euh
donc là il y a le hasard le talent le
destin la Providence choisin chacun
choisit comme il a envie de le formuler
et qui sauve le monde ça veut dire
l'homme qui a sauvé le monde c'est
Churchill c'est pas Roosevelt et à
l'inverse quel est l'homme ou la femme
de pouvoir qui vous a le plus séduit ou
qui vous séduit le plus parce que vous
êtes éogieux dans ce livre avec Joe
Biden par exemple aujourd'hui euh c'est
pour ça que je vais le dire sur la
planète démocratique un seul homme
m'impressionne c'est Joe Biden je pense
que Joe Biden est sur le plan intérieur
probablement le meilleur président
démocrate depuis Roosevelt et sur le
plan extérieur le meilleur président
démocrate depuis trumman alors vous
allez me dire que je fais encore l'éloge
de l'expérience dans l'assemblée de
vieux qui règne ici ou de disons
d'adultes avancés mais c'est la manière
dont il a réagi sur le plan
international à l'Ukraine la finesse
avec laquelle il gère le conflit
moyenne-oriental c'est à la fois alors
Biden ou l'administration Biden peu
importe Biden est aussi le nom de marque
unee administration exceptionnelle et
donc l'homme d'État aujourd'hui auquel
il faut rendre hommage c'est lui et il
faut tellement espérer qu'il soit réélu
alors face à Trump mais évidemment c'est
une affaire de salut publici mais même
s'il avait un adversaire républicain
civilisé il faudrait souhaiter qu'il
soit réélu est-ce que si vous faites un
prochain livre à la main que vous
rajouteriez des noms Gabriel Atal à a
Gérald Armana à D non mais ça dans ce
cas-là il faudrait faire un livre qui
est un livre pour classe élémentaire
quoi ils sont débutants son nom mais bon
ils ont leur avenir devant eux mais
arrêtons vous pouvez pas
quand vous voyez le problème
d'expérience qui a manqué à Macron et
Macron est intellectuellement
culturellement supérieur à tous ces
hommes de très très loin bon donc ça va
qu'ils y aillent doucement hein ou là là
ils vont voir que et en particulier
Gabriel Atal bon il a démarré comme un
sprinter mais un jour di agéi le
légendaire agnéi m'a dit parlant de
quelqu'un c'est un sprinter mais la vie
est est un marathon et je pense que
c'est ça que ces jeunes gens devraient
méditer et on en revient à la question
du temps dont vous nous parliez oui ah
le temps l'expérience
acquise une forme d'accumulation
primitive du savoir comme Marx dit qu'il
y a une accumulation primitive du
capital merci àin min merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pour cet
entretien on revoit votre livre
dictionnaire amoureux du pouvoir séchz
plomb merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pour cette entretien on passe au
club des territoires